hello sweet internet i'm gav i'm dan
that's dj dan we're the slow-mo guys a
while ago we did a video where we spun a
cd so fast
it shook itself to pieces it sort of
warbled and then
flung out warbled yeah right okay well
this time
we've got some records we're kicking at
old school yeah
i feel bad breaking these to be honest
yeah it's almost like ripping a book
it's just not to be done is it i know
you mean but we i did get them from
goodwill yeah so i feel like people are
done with them they've experienced it
now we're going to put them to a second
use in a second life so
immortalized forever on the internet so
this is the loading procedure
if you didn't see the previous video
then i'll explain
something this is actually the motor
from inside of a
i think it's a dyson so it can spin at
incredibly high speeds
i think that's probably all right god
imagine putting a needle on this what it
would sound like
it would be it's already kind of wonky
this record isn't perfectly straight you
know when you see them being played on a
gramophone they kind of go like
yeah like that i don't know if this is
going to survive long
so because we're just using the motor
from a dyson it's an incredibly fast
hoover motor that's how it works it
spins really fast
but if you just turn it on straight away
it would be spinning at maximum speed
and that's just kind of not what we want
we want to get the gradual
build up and then eventually the braking
of the record so for that we're going to
use this variac
which means that you put the you put a
voltage through it and you can vary the
output
increasing it gradually until we hit
that exact breaking point we need
i'm excited yeah me too slightly scared
too yeah it makes a hell of a noise
it's really intimidating shooting on the
v2640 we're gonna start at 12 and a half
thousand frames a second
i think if this works we'll paint one
all right one
different quadrant so you can see it
spin better sounds good to me
this damn vice is going everywhere this
thing is so powerful it's like shaking
the vice everywhere it's like tightening
it down
[Music]
god that goes that goes
whoa look at this oh it's like colored
it's turned it into
oh geez that's crazy how did it go
oh it just got eviscerated i think oh
look there's a big chunk of it there
that's a big chunk okay
yeah i was all the way over there and
some tiny little like tiny little
fragments were like bounced off of this
went
little bits of musical dust yeah dust
yeah i think that was you know what i
think that took more
than the cd really i think so look what
it's done to the wood here
oh it's like embedded itself in the wood
fully almost cracked the wood open this
is
lethal i'm actually glad we put these up
yeah
you know i was getting worried that we
were going to send it across the
fences well if there's pieces like this
then it's possible at this speed it's
almost like you could play the music at
it yeah this is the music speed
yeah this is what she was actually this
is slowed down to be oh
yes now it's warping uh you can see on
the reflection that it's going a bit
it must just happen at a certain speed
where it's like and now i'm walking
it's weird because it stabilizes
initially
there's like a chunk of it still on
there god okay let's do that frame by
frame okay so it's split
from the middle see that crack yeah i
see that
worked its way through turned into like
a tree either side
that's so weird it looks like lightning
going through it it pretty much does and
that means that
one like each of those halves is now
like really vulnerable to cracking and
then
oh and the other look on the left
they're just going they just turn to
glass like they just turn to dust it's
kind of good that we've got the blocks
there because it show it like
shatters it after it's gone yeah because
there were some big chunks coming out of
that let's i think we should move the uh
blocks on the right side just slightly
further away
oh it's just the edge i think just for
safety we should build up one higher
you think so yeah like this is coming
off as some ridiculous clip
lots of riches some clip because we've
got enough light i'm just going to
change the shutter angle to 90 degrees
each exposure is now 20 microseconds
approximately
which should well get rid of half the
motion blur oh i also need a shield
i'll just hide behind that wood thing
or the tree too far away too far away
yeah the wires don't reach
yep
[Applause]
whoa
i was like there's not much more to give
on this really
yeah i was nearly full whack there i was
there's surely no way it's at its full
speed with that on it like the
the motor is only going to spin a small
fan but because maybe because the record
is heavier
it's slowing it down more so it's not
being able to get the same rpm
yeah this one's cracked slightly
different it's not in such a straight
line
it's gone like sideways you can see the
marks that it's left on the
on the brick really yeah you wanna watch
this
okay you ready
that one was different because it crept
from the outside
see the crack at the bottom now yeah
three
four five six seven eight nine frames it
was gone
that broke really similarly to the cd
yeah that was
because it broke from the outside that
was exactly how the cd went and then it
just
misted itself it's like glitter look at
the sparkle
so let's move everything six feet back
oh god
there's so much effort to move those
kind of blocks it's ridiculous
so we thought we'd make it easier to to
be able to do maths on this
so we painted quadrants well you painted
i say i painted quadrants it's not
really
it's a blue is questionable it's got
sort of a slightly bigger piece of the
pie
you just complain about everything don't
you i can't do anything right
you didn't say do like an amazing job of
it i just it was just like a basic thing
sorry i didn't measure it out to the
millimeter god
should i put the should i preface
everything now oh by the way do an
amazing job on it yeah
otherwise i'll just do a shoddy job
obviously i like it i think it's funny
okay it's locked in there so let's play
a guessing game
yeah so there's always a piece that goes
straight up and doesn't shatter
what color do you think it will be i
reckon blue oh yellow yellow
for sure all right i wonder what color
that'll look like when it's spinning
i mean if it was red green and blue it
would appear white but because the
yellow
appear yellow yeah maybe let me just
document your
shield all right well first of all i've
got to be in comfort so i've got a nice
uh recliner behind here yeah so that i
can do it in comfort and second of all
that's your period i'm hidden behind
here with the variac
i'll use my head to shield myself
turn it on and then just like
[Music]
golly gosh me
so i ended up breaking 115 there
but it's only got this much more to give
so it's really at the limits of hungry
yeah it really is angry lad
yeah there's another crack from the
outside that one shall see
[Music]
oh wow it looks cool with the colors
isn't it it's like a really convoluted
way of painting
yeah blue went up damn it
without even seeing the slo-mo you can
tell which colors went where
because if you look green is all at the
bottom there you follow it around and
it's all the red
then it slowly turns to blue well that's
that's why the sky is blue
yeah got me the last of that
and then there's more blue and then it
goes yellow i think it broke more or
less perfectly in quarters
blue yellow green red we're now looking
at this edge
to see how much it warps
[Music]
i thought the whole wood top went oh
geez
oh look at that look at the damage it's
done here
oh god that's insane
it's insane it looks like scarring look
you can see the individual
pieces that have hit it and the way the
fact they've gone more wobbly
as it goes along and then come back
again look it's gone like you can see a
graph
where it's gone wobbly and then not so
wobbly i bet if it carried on it'd be
like this
like a wave it's a way to record
onto a physical medium yeah it's like an
instant graph
it goes like this like that and then it
comes back around again
and it goes like a wave all the way
around
i bet that's exactly what you'll see on
the slimmer that is a severe amount of
water
wow i'm surprised this even managed to
stay in focus
it's moving around so much just pulling
isn't it it really is oh it's fish in
the middle
oh did it yeah oh wow
i was hoping it would split exactly on
the on the front focus line well that
would be
amazing i wonder what the
like how much centimeters wise it was
actually
varying in wobblemen i guess we'll just
do one more
tada what a beaut thank you this one is
being shot square
so we can stabilize it in post and spin
the shot
in theory i've also got the wood in the
shot so if we see any of that scarring
we'll go to see how i did it
oh yeah powering up engines starting jet
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good lord one came directly at this
thing
did it i heard it audibly like go
there must have been a rebound there's
no way it would have come straight out
yet no exactly it must have like
rebounded off the
off the stone oh from the outside again
from the blue
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
so let's see which pick came at you so
it came off the corner
that must have been what hit you you
think so it must
it was kind of the same sort of angle
look at how fast that's spinning towards
her
i definitely i almost felt it though so
it must have been a chunky piece
did you say my name huh a chunky piece
yes my nickname look at the 3d
nature of some of this stuff it's just
absolutely compressed
get some side on it looks like someone's
taken like mascara
and wiped it on a brick wall look it
looks like someone's just going like
yeah yeah that's some more you know
what's good about that video what's that
we've shattered all the records is that
good
what do you mean like you're doing a
record-breaking pun
well yeah yeah you know what with your
puns you're like one of these
like broken record
there you go that was insane we never
had this cage around it last time when
it was the cd
because it was so light it just lost all
its velocity like the drag from all the
air just slowed it all down
this stuff this could have gone miles
well the very fact that this still
exists
after hitting the cage yeah she tells
you like this is super thick as well
right in the middle
it's the records are thicker than they
are on the outside so the outside bits
hit this and turn to dust and these
would go
flying but luckily most of the energy is
taken out by hitting them yeah these
parts are bigger a because they were in
the center
and they were released at a slower
velocity and also the label sort of
holds it together
yeah that was crazy i'm glad it's over
because that was kind of scary
what i might do i might take a picture
of these and post it on twitter and i'll
say
you'll never guess how we painted these
bricks no one will get i don't think
anyone's going to know no one
but i don't think a record has ever been
used in that way before
no no well that was a that was a
record-breaking
record breaking yeah i think it was
i think it was a it was a
record-breaking squad
god well that was cool
hopefully you enjoyed that video feel
free to subscribe
to our very channel right here we've got
a second one as well behind the scenes
i play pranks on down a lot don't i yeah
you do yeah i do
and uh all the social medias and stuff
thank you very much for watching do you
know um
in the future yeah when like you know
how we have like archaeologists that
would go to places like
rome and greece and yeah and piece
together all the pottery and be like
this was used to store grain
do you think in the future they'll find
these and be like
well and they'll glue one of these all
together it
appears to have been shattered apart by
itself yeah
yeah this is where you grow graves
that's what they sound like or
the guy from time team he was like right
this
this the guy that wasn't talking
the one with the long hair it was
clearly faking a west country
yeah as soon as he got on camera he was
just like oh you talk like this now
i just talked like this normally and
then uh cut thank you thank you
yeah yeah they get in the trailer yeah